hi everyone thank you for tuning in to
the Scout focus on combating AI bias in
healthcare I'm Sarah Seibert senior
researcher with gov CIO media and
research and I'll be moderating this
discussion with me we have Gil
alterovitz director of the Department of
Veterans Affairs National artificial
intelligence Institute and Samir antani
principal investigator at the National
Library of Medicine thank you both for
joining me today
oh thank you for having us thank you for
having us yeah so to start our
conversation could you provide a brief
overview of your position and how you
work with AI Samir would you like to
start sure thanks so I'm a principal
investigator at the National Library of
Medicine at the National Institutes of
Health and what that merely means is I'm
a scientist and I've been so for about
two decades now
I have been a career uh scientist at the
nlm looking on at various aspects of
understanding visual as an image content
with medical images from the perspective
of retrieval and more lately with terms
of understanding the content as it
relates to diseases in these images and
that translates to applying machine
learning algorithms and AI algorithms
for detecting these
that sounds really interesting I'm
looking forward to learning
learning and Gil what's your background
uh certainly so um right now I'm over
here as the Director of the national
artificial intelligence Institute which
um is seeking to build that AI capacity
and enable uh research and development
and translating that into uh the health
and well-being of our veterans right
that's uh our Central Mission and to do
that we're working on in a number of
areas whether it be to enable the people
to do uh that work the um the right
policies the right
um the right Partnerships uh the right
pilots and and related projects uh to
move forward in that area
it's really cool and I've Loved tracking
your work so how do you each defined by
us especially when we're talking about
bias and Healthcare Samir would you like
to start so bias um as it relates to
artificial intelligence algorithms uh is
the the notion that the the
decisions or the predictions made by
these methods are favoring one group uh
whether fairly or unfairly uh rather
than giving a balanced decision uh that
is more cognizant of the problem at hand
and not so much uh affected by the
training data that went into uh
itself
okay so so thanks so much for that
question on bias I think I'd agree with
Samir on on that I I just also want to
add that there's also kind of an area
that may be broader than
um and rather than looking at
demographic balance and data
representativeness and uh we often also
look at the nist definition and to look
at other areas such as so we can have
systemic bias we can have computational
statistical biases and human cognitive
biases
um where uh that may relate to how an
individual or group May perceive an AI
system and that information uh when
they're making a decision or when
they're filling and missing information
and and how humans really think about
uh how these AI systems work how they
function and their overall role and
their purpose
right yeah that makes a lot of sense and
Samir you alluded to some of your work
in your intro but I'd be interested in
learning more about how you're using AI
to identify and combat diseases and
health risks
well certainly so what I what I listed
off uh in the in the intro was I think
of the object of my um research interest
as the medical image or the medical
video uh depending on the modality that
is being used for detecting disease it
could be echocardiography videos for
example that's one interesting area that
we have where we are tracking cardiac
myopathy for sickle cell disease
patients uh and uh we are applying
machine learning to actually detect the
right atrial pressure automatically and
make it consistent with human
observations therefore bringing in as a
degree of standardization across all
these automated predictions a similar
work is being done with oral cancer we
also have uh uh detecting
tuberculosis in HIV positive and HIV
negative individuals both adults and
children the children tends to be a
little harder problem to solve and
there's some published work with uh were
working with many years with the NCI on
uh on cervical cancer for women
detecting it reliably and and observing
that different devices even in fact also
produce a a undesirable bias effect
where the algorithm becomes more
sensitive to some devices than others in
making a robust and reliable prediction
right that's really interesting and a
key word that popped out to me was that
standardization uh to make sure you're
combating bias and I know over the past
few years there have been several
executive orders and policies that have
come about outlining how AI should be
developed focusing on trustworthiness
and Equity so Gil could you discuss how
policy has changed or evolved as AI is
becoming increasingly more integrated
into the healthcare landscape yes I
think there have been a number of areas
that really have moved forward in this
AI space so uh you know you can always
go back more but you know if we go back
uh you know the last uh you know a
little over five years ago then you you
go to
um the national or the first national AI
research and developments uh strategic
plan that was released around uh
2016-ish
[Music]
um and uh that was looking at these
overall in overall strategy with the
number of principles there that continue
to develop right so things often start
in research and development and then
they uh then kind of pervade through
other areas right so after that we saw
an executive order on promoting the use
of trustworthy AI in the federal
government
um as a whole
um we also saw promoting
uh and maintaining uh American
um AI work uh that was another executive
order uh that that came out so we had 13
960 1385 nine
um that focused on enabling uh data sets
um originally around research and
development but later also uh so that
they could be used by industry and by
others um from uh different types of
data sets
um and so that really helps set the
foundation right when you have these
trustworthy AI principles which also set
up uh that executive order also set up
the responsible
um the AI officials to work together
um on these different areas and to
ensure that these principles are going
forward
um and uh another afterwards uh you know
as we see these principles then there's
also a question of
um are there more items to focus on and
how do you implement them so um there in
new things that came out just this past
year for example the White House AI Bill
of Rights which really uh provided this
blueprint to look at uh and and
principles around how do you have
Equitable and ethical use of automated
systems which uh can include those with
AI
um and then but just recently just about
a month or so ago we saw an executive
order of 14091
um which was around furthering uh
further advancing racial equity and
supporting for underserved communities
through uh the federal government and
that included this uh co-equal principle
um around uh promoting and ensuring uh
Equity as well and then we've seen
agencies coming out with things right
the va's had its uh different Frameworks
uh nist came out with the AI risk
management framework we just saw that
also a couple months ago which helped
um helps guide uh everyone around doing
their risk-based guidance for Designing
implementing and assessing these AI
systems so there's been a lot of work uh
and I think it's um interesting how it
kind of started in a sort of r d
area and then it kind of migrated to
government to enabling government and
others to do that by looking at opening
up these data sets and then migrating
toward defining principles and then
ensuring uh detailed implementation of
those principles including around ethics
and equity
right it's been really exciting to watch
that boom I think uh you joined me on
health cast at the end of 2022 and
you're like stay tuned for 2023 it's
going to be a huge year for AI and you
have not let me down on that
so Samir with all of these policies that
are coming about uh and this push to
create more trustworthy AI how are you
in your work developing algorithms and
advancing deep learning techniques to
recognize health risk predictors so I'd
like to
um break that question down a little uh
one aspect is that we look at from an um
algorithmic advancement standpoint given
a data set that is acquired um in a
clinic for example or a hospital system
or or different parts of the world at
the uh for whatever sources they might
be
you have less control on how the data
was acquired so we on one aspect we work
with advancing the technology itself
better networks that are more
exploratory about different
characteristics of the data and the
other is to study the characteristics of
the data themselves how much data do we
have have how is it distributed what is
the variety in terms of populations in
terms of disease expression in terms of
devices that were used for acquiring
these data in terms of the protocols
killing the clinical protocols that vary
uh from region to region for various
reasons uh how much do they affect the
kinds of data that you're looking at and
inherently the data quality itself all
of these factors are playing some role
even if you have the kind of data that
covers the aspect of fairness in terms
of the different ethnicities for example
or different geographical region regions
and such you still have to pay attention
to these these details and so my work in
addition to advancing uh medical AI is
also looking at at mechanisms to detect
these aspects
and uh and figure and also discover or
develop means of how can we uh adjust
and adapt to the data that we have by
either synthesizing your data or um or
in other in other ways as it's called as
pre-processing the data so that you have
a balanced data set that's been given to
the AI for learning the characteristics
of these these various diseases
right that's really interesting and uh
that leads perfectly into my next
question uh so Gil how are you improving
data management and uh your unit to have
in turn more accurate Ai and Samir if
there's anything you'd like to add uh
after Gill feel free
yeah so yeah data management it's it's
really core to not only AI but really
any kind of um inference and and
Predictive Analytics and so
um you know in that it is both used to
build a model and if you kind of think
about a model as a essentially almost
like a compressed type of data in a
sense as well so when you're ever you're
managing the models themselves and so we
have a couple different
um things going on at the at the VA if
you think about
um if they're really kind of two things
to think about how do you
um
how do you govern that data right and
there's a data governance console uh uh
where we're a member of that there and
it goes across offices
um it is uh uh something that brings
together a number of different offices
uh at the VA
um there is a a structure kind of a with
a number of different subconsuls under
that
um there's also uh different work groups
such as data analytics work group where
we can learn from each other uh around
different um items in this area
um and so that's kind of one one Avenue
the other is uh thinking about and kind
of uh
building and enabling uh these different
uh structures in a way that can be used
by the different uh parties right and so
uh thinking about a um and leveraging
kind of this single
um veteran data object
um for for planning for doing analytics
uh that's one of the things that's being
looked out
um at the VA as well
um and then collaborations you know
learning from how uh different offices
are uh working with data and other
agencies right so there's some data for
example that is within the VA but then
there's others that may be linked and
it's in other agencies so
um for example CMS right like a lot of a
lot of veterans will actually get uh
their drug based uh benefits through CMS
right as they're older uh through
programs like that and so there's ways
to link that data and agreements uh and
understandings to be able to work with
the data like that from other agencies
as well so with that I'll pass it on I
guess to Samir uh as well a casino is
part of HHS I know you interact with
them as well
no I think Gill you covered the topic
fairly well
um uh the only point I'd add is uh in
the in the aspect on the technology side
in the aspect of detection of fairness
in the algorithms you have to be aware
of which are the sensitive variables and
which are those that are more resilient
to change and may not affect uh the
outcome as much and and balancing access
uh management of data and the uh the
development of these algorithms uh is
like three three legs of a stool if you
will and they all have to work in in
balance
right that's a great way to put it so
Samir as you're developing these Tech
tools and Innovative techniques to
improve health care how are you
combating algorithmic bias to improve
treatment and care for minority
populations uh so the way that's that's
a tough one to answer from for a
researcher especially because we are so
headstrong in trying to build the next
better algorithm uh with whatever data
we have access to that uh very often the
first uh reaction is let me build
something and then uh but the the nature
of the game also is to publish the work
that we do and so what we also don't
want to be doing is leading people to
believe that your method is has also
been tested for fairness and and that's
one aspect that we have become very
sensitive lately uh in looking at these
algorithms that are uh that are
particularly getting tuned to search
certain features that are so strong but
might be excluding certain segments of
society perhaps uh in in so it is it is
a tug in both directions in one one one
one side there is very little annotated
uh Medical Data available particularly
in the Imaging space that has been
verified and validated by clinicians for
developing these algorithms on the other
side given that you have sparse data or
highly skewed data you want to get as
wider the geographic distribution as you
can and the two examples that we have in
uh in some of my research uh is one that
was I was talking alluding to cervical
cancer earlier
15 to 18 sites worldwide are beginning
to contribute their their studies toward
This research therefore uh therefore
diversifying the kinds of images that
come into this to the research platform
if you will
but also uh pressing before us as
researchers the issues that when you
have a diverse data set and you train on
one kind and you start testing on the
other kind uh you have the issues of
catastrophic forgetting which is where
it starts uh Shifting the domain from
one to the other uh Etc the other work
that I'm doing with this uh with
pediatric TV in HIV positive and
negative kids is that we are seeking
data from 12 different sites worldwide
something analogous to the cervical
cancer work but again the emphasis there
is to get as wider distribution as
possible that covers
the various protocols and expressions of
disease
at the same time we have to disambiguate
now was it the protocol that caused the
bias to appear which which it will and
you have the control for that or was it
the device that did it or was it the
kind of disease that's prevalent in that
region power world that did it and so as
research researchers we are constantly
in a loop if you will trying to solve
these problems and and uh and advancing
science and Healthcare
right that makes a lot of sense and I
know that VA recently established its AI
institutional review board and the AI
oversight committee the adds that layer
of governance so Gail what is the intent
of these groups and how do they evaluate
the fairness and transparency of using
AI tools within research and clinical
operations right right as you mentioned
uh the really the the goal is to enable
um the us to look at these different
issues around
um around bias around these trustworthy
IAI principles uh that are encoded in
these executive orders uh 13960
14091 as well as uh overall principles
and AI Bill of Rights and so forth so
what we do is actually
um have the these committees are these
institutional review boards for example
they're already existing in these
different medical centers they are
already reviewing different research and
development proposals that's kind of
like one side of the coin so to speak
um and what we are have basically added
is an AI module that gives them
additional questions additional things
to think about as they are starting to
look at projects that now include that
uh so just as an example of transparency
you know maybe an issue on the models
and so forth and so a couple of these
projects were identified like that
um and then uh and then looked at to
make it ensure that that they were more
transparent
um the other aspect as I mentioned
that's kind of one side of the coin that
r d which is often uh kind of at that
Leading Edge uh also in terms of the
looking at the policies and so forth and
then the second piece is uh clinical uh
types of operations right at Medical
Center uh which is part of the uh
oversight uh boards that uh we now have
a pilot of that ongoing
um uh in uh Long Beach uh and there are
other sites that have expressed an
interest to kind of learn from from that
work uh to look at uh when there are
different
um items that are looking to be using
clinical operation before they actually
get used
um and so there are some similarities
and differences right they both look at
projects before
essentially they are launched I would
say right so that's kind of good to uh
make sure that things are kind of um
known early uh they both have mechanisms
to ensure
um kind of said guard rails on projects
and so forth
and they're not the only I just want to
mention they're not the only ones that
we have right so as part of the
governance council is part of the work
uh that we're doing the there are a
number of other projects other than
clinical other than uh these r d
projects that are also looked at in
within the requirements of exist within
the year 3960 to make sure that they're
following these different principles and
and they and and they get done from the
design stage until the end that's I
think what's really important that you
don't kind of wait until it's already uh
running but as soon as possible when
it's being designed to make sure that
you look at any issues around bias and
so forth from the beginning uh so that
you're using the right data sets before
you actually are building the model
right that makes a lot of sense and I
know being
would be a huge 400 000 employees I
think the last time I checked and a
bunch of different medical centers so as
you're integrating AI what role does
Workforce training play in ensuring that
it's trustworthy and ethical and what
are some of va's training programs that
are supporting that yes it's uh you know
I think Workforce if you think about it
that's a really great way to get at all
the things that I mentioned from the
beginning right because if you have a
trained Workforce they will know to
ensure to look at further uh to make
sure that their data sets are not biased
to make sure that they're building the
models in a correct way right in a way
that doesn't introduce new um issues as
well uh and to validate and so forth
right and so
um there are a number of different
Workforce programs and there are a
number ones that are being looked at in
the future uh there's there's one we
recently uh had an event for actually
the uh Aspire program which is uh you
know all services Personnel Readiness
um uh engine uh which is basically
um a way to assess people's knowledge uh
and then um and find the the right
custom path for them given their current
uh Knowledge and Skills and so uh that
is one program that um we are piloting
and we're working with a number of other
agencies as well we recently had an
event around one of the the pilot
results from that
um and there are other ones as well and
so what we do is we learn from these and
then we can see which uh which which
path can really be uh great to move
forward and that's another area where we
actually learn you know there are other
agencies I think you mentioned the B is
very is large right it's the largest
civilian agency uh We've um been
interacting with and learning from other
agencies and we on what they're looking
at because we're all facing some of the
same issues uh on the workforce right
it's their issues around retention
recruitment uh talent development of
people who are already in the VA who may
be able to uh do certain AI roles
whereas where they were not originally
trained for that right
um so those are all different pieces
sort of of the puzzle around Workforce
yeah the Aspire program is super cool I
love learning more about that
so you mentioned that you're integrating
Lessons Learned I'd like to dive a
little deeper into that so for both of
you what are some of the lessons learned
through your AI work and how are you
applying them on important health
problems in the current landscape Samir
would you like to start sure so uh
Lessons Learned I think we are
constantly learning lessons all the time
it's a number of times we fall and pick
ourselves up I think is the way better
way to put it but uh we are very become
very sensitive to the very nature of AI
and medicine and Ai and Healthcare that
that it is inherently data Centric uh it
also is uh affected by uh the the the
the use of of medical technology that
resulted in the capturing of the data
itself and so you're sort of dealing
with both aspects and trying to just
ambiguate these uh toward meeting the
clinical goal so so as uh as a
researcher of course we um like I said
before we are constantly trying to uh
improve uh the algorithmic performance
the reliability uh in the predictions uh
avoiding flip-flopping uh sometimes
bizarre flip-flopping where the same
patient who we know has disease appears
at a future visit and is classified or
misclassified as being disease free
which is
um unlikely and not true so uh detecting
these instance level failures and
combining them with more uh systemic uh
challenges that the model at large may
be having and correcting at these both
these levels is an important aspect of
our work
right that makes a lot of sense and Gil
in terms of Lessons Learned how are you
implementing those
yes I I think when you have Lessons
Learned uh I think what you basically do
is or what we've been looking at you
know kind of this iterative approach
right so maybe the best ways you know to
look at an example right so in covid you
may have for example a predictive model
uh and it may be perfectly suitable at
that point in time in covet right but as
you have new variants over time
um you may have model drip right and you
so you kind of need to keep updating the
model you need kind of this learning
um Healthcare System
um and uh there may also be differences
in that you know model maybe or you know
at some point
you see that you know in the early days
right that it was uh cover was kind of
moving different geographical regions
right and so a model built in one place
may not apply to another
um similarly with models built outside
the VA would they work in the VA that is
a common one that we often need to look
at and so being able to
have a way to evaluate different models
in different situations and then quickly
leverage that knowledge to make an
update that is something that I think
we've seen uh that's kind of in the
model predicting building area and then
in in the kind of the policy area this
is a fast-moving field right as you said
2023 is kind of becoming this year of
the AI in some sense so it seems almost
every day there's a new announcement of
something
um and a lot of there are a lot of
things especially around that new
generative AI space right and so when
you have a new area there's sometimes
new types of risks and benefits to look
at you know people talk about
um you know there's this issue around
the so-called hallucination right these
models it's something that didn't really
exist in in certain types of other AI
models that were in the past used for
chat Bots and so forth right and so
um the lesson is really to always when
there's a new technology to be able to
evaluate because it may have new types
of risks even though it looks the same
to the world like oh this is a chatbot
or you know but it now has different
potential risks than a rule-based uh one
that may have been done just a couple
years ago
right that makes a lot of sense and I
think that leads perfectly into the last
question so with the boom of AI in 2023
that we've seen so far uh what do you
both think the future of AI and
Healthcare looks like Samir would you
like to start sure so
looking at looking out of the window
from a researcher's desk at the world
and the impact that AI is having and can
have I'm forever the uh the hopeful uh
you know uh person who who hopes to see
it making a great uh impact uh reducing
the uh the errors that occur in clinical
practice enhancing the efficiencies for
the clinicians uh so that they can they
can provide the best care that that is
possible and it can serve as a
meaningful adjunct to the
decision-making process in the clinical
workflow so but all of these dreams are
driven by by two factors the r d engine
and the controls that are put in place
uh through any of the policies and uh
and implementation details of the
engineering of the AI so
um I I look forwardly outside
yeah I'm looking forward to it too and
Gail what are you looking forward to or
what do you expect yeah yeah well I I
think there's
um you know there's some things that you
can see ahead right
um by just looking at what's going on in
r d Laboratories and so forth and then
there's sometimes things that just kind
of they lead to kind of this uh
exponential jump right and I think we
are essentially at this kind of moment
where
um AI is able to do some things as well
as humans in some task areas right and
that number is growing larger
um and that once it kind of passes that
it grows it continues to grow
exponentially whereas you know human
capabilities you know through Evolution
you know it's growing much more slowly
right and so I think we'll be really
surprised by that exponential growth and
capabilities of the ones where it is uh
right now at the level of human uh level
uh perception in a number of areas
um will be you move very quickly
soon and so some of these areas I think
um will be in the generative AI space
that we we've seen
um I think we've seen a lot in the text
area but that integration of text
Imaging sound all of those different
modalities is going to enable uh new
types of medicine to be done in a more
efficient way than it was in the past
we're gonna you know of course have to
deal with some of the new risks that
there are and that's right it's going to
be important to have the human the loop
and that's another reason why I think in
the future some of the things that we'll
see well it may seem really exciting
that you know around diagnosis and all
that I think we'll see a lot in the
efficiency things kind of behind the
scenes that's where I think we'll see a
lot of things where you also have a
human in the loop looking at uh at that
um and where uh you can we'll see a lot
of increases in efficiency that will
give Physicians caregivers others more
time to work with a patient less time
taking notes and doing administrative
tasks
right that's really exciting and I'm
looking forward to seeing how this goes
and I would love to touch base with both
of you again soon I love hearing your
thoughts about this topic so thank you
both again for joining me today I
appreciate you taking the time well
thank you sir I think I think this was a
fantastic opportunity uh to to talk
about this important topic uh because AI
bias in healthcare uh like like we just
discussed right now as tremendous
promise and also has a fair number
amount of risk that needs to be
controlled and and it's good to see that
various parts of the government are are
are not only funneling the r d effort to
advance the science but also applying
the necessary policy controls to ensure
that that there is uh risk mitigation to
the best possible and I've known and
worked with Gill for a long time on
various of the Committees and I'm happy
to have him with me as a collaborator
and colleague on the on the show
you know thank you thank you Sarah Samir
it's great to be on with you all uh
again it's uh a number of times that
we've we've had interactions before and
uh you know it's really just I think
fascinating to see how much even since
our last conversations right AI has uh
Advanced some things that
um you know maybe were not uh as an
imaginable of being uh having such a
large impact on our population
um you know across the US population
potentially uh is something that we now
see right it has gone from uh small
Pilots to you know at the VA we've got
um looking at you know actually using AI
in um you know uh different AI assisted
colorectal screening you know it's
happening in actual locations you know
Richmond uh Albuquerque Tucson Hudson
Valley uh Iron Mountain across the VA
you know these things are now uh coming
into play and helping patients and today
and I appreciate you both thank you
again and I hope you have a great rest
of your day
[Music]